hey guys mkbhd here and welcome to a
high definition video review of the ikea
audio m808 v2 professional studio
monitors
studio monitors are the types of
headphones that professional uh video
creators and audio producers actually
use to monitor their sound so i suppose
you could consider this a pre warning
before the video even starts that these
speakers are not for everyone but if
you're in the range for an extremely
high end video series and actually a
first in the mkbhd series of video
reviews and i might as well break it to
you now these speakers are the first
ever to get a 10 out of 10 by my review
process so if you're interested stay
tuned
now visually you can tell these speakers
are pretty appealing and you can also
tell that they're made of a combination
of two things they have an internal
amplifier for each studio monitor the
bottom part is an eight inch woofer not
a subwoofer but a woofer and the top
part is a one inch soft dome tweeter and
i know a lot of you guys are probably
thinking i like these speakers because
they're red and black but let me tell
you the audio quality that you get from
the superior build quality of these
monitors is absolutely amazing i have
the laptop in between them here so you
can get a good size difference that is a
17.3 inch laptop and the monitors
themselves are over a foot tall so
you're going to have to make sure you
have enough room on your desk or
possibly your studio setup to have room
for these monitors now i've zoomed in at
the bottom here and that's to take a
look at the seven inch wide slot that
allows for airflow to go under the
speakers and out the front as the woofer
does actually move a little bit while
the base is pumping now i do actually
have to mention one thing although this
isn't technically a subwoofer it is an
eight inch driver so it's pretty big and
you're going to get a very nice
frequency distribution chart and you're
pretty much going to have a completely
flat response so you won't get an
extremely high amount of bass or high
amount of highs the tweeter and the
woofer are very nicely balanced out so
that giant driver isn't going to be a
problem and doesn't actually move that
much it does have a nice crisp clean
base so to take a closer look at the
back of the speakers they're actually
not that bad a lot of studio monitors
can be complicated to use you have your
volume dial minus six decibels to plus
three decibels and you also have your
high frequency adjustment in case you're
just not getting enough highs you can
turn that up i have mine at zero you
also have your balance and xlr cables
you'll have to purchase those probably
about eight bucks a piece on amazon and
you have your power cable and your power
on and off switch so all in all pretty
simple for a nice high and professional
studio monitor
so overall yes like i mentioned before
this is the first and the one and only
product to actually receive a 10 out of
10 by the mkbhd review standards which
is absolutely exceptional as i couldn't
find anything wrong with the product
itself the one downside could possibly
be that with the premium price you're
playing paying you're not actually going
to get the xlr cables but like i said
those are fairly inexpensive online
overall make sure you do have them not
positioned as i do here but at a 45
degree angle with them both facing you
so you do end up in the sweet spot
between the two speakers the free spot
the sweet spot is actually pretty big
and you'll be able to get absolutely
amazing sound out of the ikea audio m808
v2 studio monitors so this has been
mkbhd with the video review hope you
like this one and stay tuned for the
next week video thanks for watching guys
peace